the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
good well why don't we go ahead and get
started we're going to be discussing
photovoltaic efficiency measurement and
theoretical limits and there'll be
plenty of natural breaks over the course
of today's presentation for us to have a
debate this is kind of fun fun lecture
because we start out by talking about
how to measure solar cell device
efficiency later we will discuss the
theoretical efficiency limits of solar
cells why do we focus an entire lecture
on efficiency well first as we discussed
previously efficiency is a very strong
determining factor for cost the
rationale again is that if you have low
efficiency you're going to need more
commodity materials to make a given what
peak that means you'll need a larger
area of solar cell to solar a module to
make a certain amount of power which
means you need more glass encapsulants
and so forth so efficiency is a strong
lever determining cost of all downstream
components except for the area
independent factors like the inverter
secondly efficiency is tricky to measure
accurately that is why there only a few
laboratories around the world handful
that are certified to measure solar cell
efficiencies these are the efficiencies
that could be reported and say the
efficiency compendiums that an example
of which you've just picked up here is
one of the readings the reality is that
we can measure efficiency or get a
pretty close value for an efficiency of
a device within our own laboratories but
there are a number of possible errors
that can creep up and nip us in the heel
if we're not careful and that's why we
spend some time in today's lecture
discussing those potential pitfalls and
thirdly there are new technologies that
are being promised right and left to
overcome some of the fundamental limits
of traditional solar cell devices like
this one right here and we have to
understand what those limits are so that
we can design better ways to overcome
them so learning objectives a bit of a
small font here but the idea is a very
first point is to identify the sources
of record solar cell efficiencies to
understand where one goes to look them
up how do you find the record efficiency
of say a silicon device or a cigs device
eventually we'll talk about measurement
of solar cell efficiency
and finally the theoretical or
fundamental limits to solar cell
efficiencies so the key concepts for
learning objective number one to
identify a source for record
efficiencies my go-to place is a
progress in photovoltaics it's a journal
in the PV field and every six months p
IP also progress in photovoltaics p IP
comes out with solar cell efficiency
tables led by one of their editors
martin green professor at University of
New South Wales in Australia the latest
addition that I could find was version
38 I believe this was from July or June
this summer and every six months or so
they come out with a new version and
what you'll find inside of that paper
this is one of the four handouts that
you have today one of the three articles
that you have what you'll find inside of
a typical Martin green solar cell
efficiency table is a listing of in
table one a listing of individual cells
and table two of modules and within the
cells any new record efficiency will be
shown in bold so this over the six
months preceding the release of the
latest version there were indeed four
record efficiencies that had been made
and that's pretty impressive advanced
note one thing which we'll come back to
later note the plus/minus appearing here
after the efficiency number is anybody
surprised at that number Ashley did you
expect it to be that big
not that big right but say the record
efficiency crystalline silicon device
25% plus or minus 0.5 it's pretty pretty
large Delta will explain some of the
reasons why that that error bar is so
large another thing to keep in mind look
at gallium arsenide at 28.1% just
achieved by Alta devices in March keep
that number 28 point 1 plus or minus 20
percent in your mind at least the first
one twenty eight point one will march on
to the module efficiency tables right
here so now the gallium arsenide the
module efficiency record for the
efficiency tables right here is twenty
one percent or twenty one point one
percent crystalline silicon has dropped
from twenty five to twenty three and so
forth and and this is fairly typical
that record module efficiencies are in
the order of two to seven percent lower
than record efficiency cells can anybody
guess why that might be
yep you have a mix of different
performers and when you connect them in
series and in parallel you're going to
be limited by the lowest voltage or
current respectively right yes okay
so certainly there are there are
mismatches between the individual
devices inside of a module that's where
the majority of that comes from for say
crystalline silicon or discrete
monolithic wafers but how about for some
of these thin film devices they're
deposited using these large chemical
vapor deposition reactors for example or
PVD reactors and you deposit a uniform
thin film over a large area you use
lasers to cut little trenches in the
films and discretize the devices that
way so there how come there are
differences between records cell and
record module for thin film
inhomogeneous exactly so if you have
inhomogeneities and thickness or in
composition or even in surface quality
from region to region in that large area
you are likely to reduce your
performance one analogy since I know
many of you are mechanical engineers one
analogy to this is when you're doing
tensile tests with ceramics or brittle
specimens at room temperature and you
pull on your specimen and you obtain a
certain fracture stress you then take
that smaller piece pull again now the
fracture stress is higher pull on that
smaller piece that broke off yet again
another fracture stress is even higher
in other words in that large specimen
there was one point that was extremely
weak another point that was sort of weak
and another point that was mildly weak
right and as you as you increase the
size of your specimen the likelihood of
having one of these failure points
increases that's an analogy let's say to
a large area module as well that we
could have pinholes or other
manufacturing defects inside of a large
area module that could reduce a
performance locally and because
everything is interconnected it tends to
drop the performance overall so we have
the record laboratory efficiencies this
is another reference source
I am not personally aware where Larry
Casimir Sookie publishes this on a
regular basis I know he maintains this
table and if you email him very nicely
he'll email you back with the most
updated version but I'm not aware of any
publication outlet where this is
regularly appearing but nevertheless it
captures the record efficiencies versus
time the same way that you too could do
if you went to the Martin green records
and I believe we're at what was it
number 39 now 38 we're at version 38 and
if you went back in time to all of the
different tables and tabulated the
results versus this time you would get a
plot that looked very similar to this
for each technology okay so next up we
are going to identify the sources of
standard solar spectrum so we know the
record efficiencies we're taking their
word for it right now that they did
everything right now we're going to
learn what that everything is and how to
do it right or at least some of the
pieces of doing it right we're going to
identify first of all the sources of
standard solar spectrum so in in one
scenario you could say well let me just
go outside and measure the solar
spectrum well if you go outside today
it's kind of cloudy the spectrum would
look very different than tomorrow and it
would be very difficult for you to
compare the performance of your device
against somebody who might be in Germany
or somebody who might be in Finland
where somebody might be in Brazil so
that's why we come up with a standard
reference solar spectrum and it's shown
right here the ASTM standard reference
spectrum is shown on the nice NRL
website for airmass zero that's and the
outer reaches of our Earth's atmosphere
and air mass 1.5 which is assumed to be
a standard in say temperate climates so
there have been numerous revisions to
the standard you might want to use the
latest one just to make sure that
everything is up to proper spec the
latest standard here the essentially
they in in very pedantic detail walk
through all of the possible scattering
mechanisms in the atmosphere and this is
their justification for the specific
solar spectrum that they are majoring
and
so you have a nice explanation in in in
much detail let me just show you once
again the standard spectrum you've seen
this before you've worked with it and
homework number believe it was one or
two and we see M zero and one point five
direct and aim one point five global and
one point five global being the capture
of sunlight from a full hemisphere
direct being looking very closely in a
very small solid angle directly at the
Sun on a sunny day given these
atmospheric conditions with a small
amount of scat atmospheric scattering
obtaining an integrated power density
watts per square meter if you integrate
over all wavelengths that's about 90% of
the global full hemisphere measurement
any questions so far about this okay so
that's pretty straightforward and the
measurement devices for the global and
direct measurement today obviously we
didn't have those fancy contraptions I
would say 60 70 years ago in quite the
same way with the same materials in the
same design and the same quality of
glass but we had other measurement
devices and you'll see in a few slides
how the solar constant has been varying
as a function of time granted the solar
output also varies but our ability to
measure the solar output varies as well
so if you look at the evolution of the
solar constant versus time this is the
number of watts per meter squared in the
outer reaches of our atmosphere so AM
zero and you can see that our values
have have changed so it's if you were to
ask is this because of the change of our
measurement capabilities or because of
the change of the solar output the
people who study the Sun will tell you
that the variation in solar output is
expected to be rather small and so the
likely origin of this large fluctuation
pre-1960 is most likely due to our
ability to measure the spectrum
accurately so next we'll describe how to
simulate the solar spectrum in the
laboratory and we'll describe how a
solar simulator works so great we have
an idealized solar spectrum right here
how do we recreate this in a laboratory
environment
how do we obtain a light source that
follows this profile exactly well
barring the ability to recreate a small
fusion source in the laboratory and the
ability to introduce exactly the right
of front Hoffer lines into our spectrum
we are not going to be able to reproduce
that exactly but we have several
techniques that come fairly close so the
solar simulator this is a schematic
coming off of the the Newport website
many of these solar simulators in the
laboratories here at MIT as you'll see
as you walk around the Newport Oriole or
related brands we have the light source
back here note the type of the lamp
right here it's a xenon arc lamp mirrors
essentially a series of of optics to
create the right form factor of the
light and ultimately work up work our
way toward a planar incoming beam and
the what's called spectral correction
filter which is right in the middle of
the optics train and that's essentially
to correct for variances between the
emission of the xenon arc lamp and the
ASTM solar spectrum as defined right
here okay and we have a shutter as well
to block the light and for example if
your device or or cell or material is is
photosensitive you might want to not
expose it for long periods of time
there's also when I say photosensitive I
don't mean that the device will stop
working under light but that the
performance will change there are
materials for example amorphous silicon
that we discussed where the performance
does change as a function of
illumination accumulative illumination
intensity so another interesting thing
to note here is that we have quasi
planar light coming in at the end of
this at the end of this optic strain but
if we're going to be measuring for
example concentrating solar cell
apparatus it's much more important to
have a higher degree of planarity of the
incoming light
and then other optics would be used one
might envision for instance increasing
the distance between the light source
and the actual sample or the optical
path length between the between the
collimating mirror and the in the sample
okay so now that we have light
approaching our our sample right here so
light is incoming on the sample we have
three things broadly that we have to
worry about we have to worry about
uniformity of the light the uniformity
from small region to region of the
illuminated area we need to worry about
spectral fidelity that means how closely
does the spectrum of our of our lamp
match the ASTM standard solar spectrum
and thirdly temporal stability that
means if I turn on the lamp this morning
and want to take in a measurement
immediately is it stable yet okay let me
wait a half hour for things - for
example the the thermal loads inside of
the system to reach equilibrium with the
environment now I'm going to measure it
what if I come back in an hour and a
half will I still get the same result
what if I come back tomorrow or next
month temporal stability is another
major concern for solar simulators on
the right hand side is just an example
of the irradiance versus wavelength of a
given light source versus time and you
can see there's a new lamp and then
after a certain work in period of a
thousand two hundred hours so we have
non-ideal matches several examples of
light sources that don't quite get it
right or have several spikes in the
output spectrum so in all cases here the
am-1 direct spectrum is shown in this -
dot line and different light sources are
shown on either solid or dashed lines so
not great and then finally we reach our
xenon arc lamp with air mass filters and
the filters are to suppress certain
peaks in certain portions general
portions of the spectrum so that we have
an approximation of our ASTM standard
reference spectrum and you notice that
it's not perfect you notice that there
are spikes in in the
the output of the xenon arc lamp as you
might expect from the the physics
involved in the light source this is of
some concern if your device is
particularly sensitive to a region a
spectral region where those might be
present so it's not a bad idea to take
to take a measurement of your light
source and actually understand how it
compares how it matches up against that
the ASTM standard spectrum in terms of
standards or ranking different types of
solar simulators there are three classes
according to the IC standards there are
as well other common standards there's a
standard use in Japan and the ASTM
standards as well but let's focus on the
the IEC 904 - 9 these are the
requirements for solar simulators
measuring crystal and silicon single
Junction devices so it's a very specific
standard and in a few slides we'll
explain what the potential differences
are when you're majoring other types of
solar cell materials we have the
spectral match or spectral fidelity we
have the non uniformity and the temporal
instability in this case since we're
defining a relatively small parameter
class a solar simulators have relatively
tight specs but you'll still notice here
that the non uniformity of the
irradiance plus or minus 2% the temporal
instability plus or minus 2% this is
where you start to see some of those
error bars on the record efficiency
measurements right so if a laboratory
has a very good handle on its
standardized or it's it's a reference
solar simulator it will be able to
calculate these effects and estimate
what their impact is on the actual solar
cell efficiency measurement
note that the temporal instability for
the Japanese standard is a little bit
more stringent than the IC just minor
detail but depending on on who your
collaborators are where they are in the
world they might be using a different
standard than you just keep that in mind
the solar simulator downstairs in in
building 35 in the laboratory that
several if you have seen yesterday we
needed the phosphorous diffusions
poke my head in and saw everybody there
so about a dozen if you might have
walked past the solar simulator in
laboratory that's a large area as in the
illuminated area at the working plane is
around 20 by 20 centimeter squared and
it is a Class A a B solar simulator so I
believe that would be spectral match
non-uniformity and then temple stability
so it's you'll typically see solar
simulators rated in this way a a Triple
A or Class B solar simulator or a a B
and so forth so again not the
significant figures that's where that
comes from it's pretty straightforward
next we're going to describe how to
accurately measure and report cell
efficiency and some common pitfalls to
avoid when actually measuring the cells
so this is really directed toward the
people who are doing active research
right now in the field of PV for those
who aren't enjoy and will come back as
soon as this a little section is over to
the debate and finally some topics of
general interest so this is just a small
subset of things to keep in mind when
you're measuring an actual solar cell
this is by no means a comprehensive list
there are indeed people who spend their
entire lives optimizing and perfecting
the art of measuring solar cells so the
very first thing that you might want to
do is is have a reference solar cell
encapsulated and then and then mailed to
you after the after a measurement is
performed at a certification laboratory
so this is an example of a very small
crystalline silicon solar cell device
inside of a an encapsulated frame and
the encapsulation is meant to prevent
any degradation to the solar cell as
well as damage that might incur during
accidental use and this cell is called a
reference cell it was tested at NREL the
current voltage the the short-circuit
current open circuit voltage and fill
factors
a feel factor that devices is well-known
and reported and it is essentially sent
with that device back to our laboratory
now whenever we want to make a new
measurement on our on any cell that we
want to measure inside the laboratory
will measure the reference cell first
just to make sure that our solar
simulators well-behaved when I say
well-behaved what could happen well one
of the many things that could happen is
that the lamp intensity decreases that's
probably the most common thing that can
happen you'll just have an overall
reduction in the output of your lamp in
which case you'll notice a reduction in
what cell parameter current voltage or
fill factor current right so light
intensity decreases you'll have a
reduction primarily in your current
logarithmic reduction in voltage all
right so you have your you have your
your standard calibrated reference cell
this is definitely something that each
laboratory that is going to be serious
about measuring efficiency should have
this is also an apparatus that doesn't
leave our laboratory except for class
purposes it's something we treat very
carefully since I think the the costs
ran and the few hundreds or thousands of
dollars avoid extraneous extent
basically avoid light from coming in
from outside of your solar simulator it
is often shown or the solar simulators
are often shown in this manner right
here where you have everything out in
the open that's to show you what's going
on inside when you actually take the
measurement typically you have a small
black curtain that's light tight around
your apparatus or maybe even a box
ensure twenty-five degrees C measurement
conditions remember that the open
circuit voltage can change depending on
the bandgap the larger the band gap is
smaller this effect the smaller the band
gap the larger this effect the vo C can
change as the temperature changes and so
it's important to have a good handle of
your temperature that means that you
might for instance have active heating
and cooling on your Chuck and you'll
also at the minimum be measuring the
temperature on top of the Chuck where
this the actual solar cell will sit not
far away or removed through some layers
of insulation away from the Chuck even
if your temperature is not precisely at
25 degrees C if you know the temperature
depend
of your solar cell you can correct for
it or account for it to pull it back to
25 degrees C next choose your probe
locations judiciously to avoid series
resistance losses let's think that
through for a second so if we have our
solar cell device right here and we're
going to be measuring its cell
efficiency if I put one little probe
right here in the corner then the
current has the current that's being
generated over here has to travel very
large distance through a lot of metal to
reach that point but if I have probes
that essentially will consist of many
different individual metal points and
they come down on either busbar like
shown right here where you see the green
right here and off of the green are many
little probe tips individual probe tips
that will make contact with the busbar
so you have essentially one coming down
right here another coming down right
here your series resistance losses will
be much less but one thing to keep in
mind is that when you do have these
probes sticking on top of your solar
cell device they will scatter some of
the light as well so there are best
practices in terms of what color they
should be and and and how tall they
should be as well so choosing the probe
location is is a large step toward
achieving high efficiencies I don't want
to under emphasize that point it really
does make a huge difference where you
put your your probe tips especially for
cells with high series resistance which
can be several the the new materials
that are being developed account for
spectral mismatch between calibration
cell and yourself let me drive that
point home so I have a crystal and
silicon calibration cell right here
I know it's spectral response I know at
what wavelengths it responds the
strongest and so it will detect any
mismatch between the ASTM standard and
the actual light source there where it
responds most strongly now let's imagine
let's imagine that I'm designing a new
organic material that responds really
well pick something in the infrared
right and so now silicon will stop
responding let's say at around 1100
nanometers so anything beyond here
silicon won't be able to detect but
let's say my device is very sense
that spectral region my silicon
calibration cell says go ahead take your
measurement everything's fine it matches
your ASTM standard but then when I stick
my cell in there all of a sudden I'm
getting a super high efficiency I just
made an organic device in my efficiency
is 11% which would be a world record I'm
ecstatic I'm really happy until I do the
quantum efficiency of both the standard
calibration cell and my new cell and I
realize wait a second they're they're
nowhere near each other in terms of
their responsivity what region of the
solar spectrum they can respond well at
and the reason I'm bringing that up is
yeah again to emphasize we have say for
example an amorphous silicon device a
gallium arsenide device over here a
SIG's device showing the different
regions of the solar spectrum the solar
spectrum shown in this dark orange in
the background right here peeking around
around 550 we can see that the different
materials are responding different
regions of the solar spectrum and
crystal and silicon would be in between
the amorphous silicon actually would be
a little further over be starting up at
around at between 1200 and 1100
nanometers so we can see how different
materials are more sensitive to
different regions of the solar spectrum
and there's even a standard test method
for determining the spectrum mismatch
parameter between your device in a
reference cell in ASTM standard for it
and the typical way to account for this
is to measure the spectral irradiance as
a function of wavelength of your light
source measure the quantum efficiency
meaning the responsivity versus
wavelength of your device and in measure
your calibration cell and using that
math you can really begin to normalize
for these extraneous effects why do I
bring that up I bring that up because
there was an example several examples of
folks in the literature I've taken off
their name so you protecting the
innocent here folks in the literature
who report very high efficiency devices
at the time was was a near-record
efficiency device what they showed were
the QE curves of their devices and in
the IV curves of their devices and you
guys in your homeworks calculated the
short-circuit current which is shown
here essentially the intercept with the
y-axis you calculated the short-circuit
current from the QE so you know how to
perform that calculation well guess what
folks at NREL also know how to do that
calculation and a whole lot more so the
folks at NREL did that and said we'll
wait a second when I do the integration
of your QE I'm not getting these short
circuit currents over here I suspect
what happened was in your solar
simulator you were using a silicon
reference cell but your cells were more
sensitive to a different region of the
solar spectrum in this particular case
they were more sensitive to the shorter
wavelengths and you didn't have a
properly calibrated solar simulator so
you're over reporting your current
outputs and of course that's very
embarrassing for a group in this
particular case there were merits on
both sides there was rebuttal to the
rebuttal so it's not a simple black and
white case for this particular story
although the logic does does fall more
strongly on one side so this is to say
avoid the sort of controversy right
perform your measurements properly don't
over report your efficiencies and when
in doubt you can always ship yourselves
to NREL or Tufano for easy or another
certified testing center and get a
certified cell efficiency then you can
place your IV curve inside of your
publication and in the little corner
over here it'll have the figure of NREL
or easy and the properly certified
information now that can be rather
complicated if you're for example
growing organic materials that degrade
quickly somehow you have to transport it
over there without degrading and that's
where arranging in advance that transfer
of the materials and perhaps even
looking into what sort of transfer
chamber you're going to encapsulate your
device and could be of interest but at
the very least please please please
remember spectral response mismatch when
you're doing efficiency measurements any
questions so far
so ed well actually doesn't make these
cells there are local companies that
live right around an rel that are
manufacturing these and putting them
together
NREL will test those cells since it
takes a few months typically to get
turnaround on a cell efficiency
measurement unless you're fast-tracked
in because your device is degrading or
you've arranged in advance and kind of
put your place in line because it takes
a few months turnaround
there's actually a premium on inventory
and so these companies will manufacture
the devices send them in get them tested
and calibrate or get the calibrated
measurements performed at NREL and then
bring them back to the company put them
on the shelf until you pick up the phone
and call them and say like a certified
cell you can actually make your own - if
you follow a set of standard protocols
that you can receive from the folks at
NREL I believe Keith Emery might be a
good point contact at first there are
very specific set of protocols that you
should follow if you want to make your
own in the lab in other words you have
to design the contacts a certain way the
encapsulants certain way make sure that
there is the the materials comprising
the remainder are black so that they
don't reflect the light black in little
details that that are only gathered by
experience if you follow all of those
parameters and and the folks over there
Keith Emery or Paul tuzik look at it and
they can SPECT it and say yeah looks
good then you can get that tested in
serve as a calibration cell as well so
you can circumvent some of the cost
associated with buying a certified cell
from a company but there is a premium to
them they tend to be they'll tend to be
particularly cheap so yeah if you if you
have another material and you'd like to
have it calibrated you can make your own
calibration reference standard as long
as it doesn't degrade question
so there are a lot of things let me let
me spend a minute waxing poetic about
the discrepancies between these cell
efficiency measurements and what actual
cells experience in the field we
understand the logic behind cell
efficiency measurements we understand
that we have to have a universal way of
comparing a cell in Japan in in Boston
in in fiber Germany so we we understand
that we need some standard method of
cell measurement this cell measurement
proves very useful when you measure the
output in terms of peak Watts because
then you can multiply by the number of
peak hours of sunlight per day and
estimate the energy output as a function
of location on the earth so it has its
uses now as to its drawbacks
we're measuring at 25 degrees Celsius
these cells are typically operating
around 60 we know that there's a voltage
drop primarily a voltage drop with
increasing temperature okay
that's point one point number two the
contacting scheme typically on these
devices in a module you'll have soldered
contacts in the front and so they make
contact with the entire bus bar but
really you know depending on your
soldering machine only in a few
locations where there's really a good
electrical contact and end on the back
and three locations so yes there are
differences in how the cell is contacted
in real life it could be one of the
reasons for discrepancies between module
and cell efficiency I'll be a probably
more one of the minor ones compared to
inhomogeneities why don't we take a
quick little pause right here before we
dive into describing the efficiency
limitations of a typical cell and get
into some cool demos at the very end
what we're going to do is have ourselves
a quick debate so I would like to call
forward at the front of the room the
representatives of the two teams one of
which is going to debate in favor of the
development of novel materials for solar
cells let me give you an example of one
material that's attracted
a bit of attention which is pyrite I can
pass this around as folks are coming up
to the front here's an example of an
iron sulfide based mineral which is
purported to have a very high degree of
manufacturability because of the large
resource abundance and also the large
refining capacity for the respective
elemental constituents there is a gap
between the performance of current
pyrite cells and their theoretical
record efficiencies quite substantial
the record efficiency being up closer to
20% the actual efficiency being down at
around 2 that is not unlike for example
tin sulfide or other related materials
let's say copper zinc tin sulfide is
probably the most advanced at around 10%
but still about half of its theoretical
limit and so the big question that we're
going to debate is does it make sense to
invest a lot of funds to come up with
these earth-abundant alternatives for
our existing solar cell materials our
cad-tel
our copper indium gallium diselenide
cognizant that the supply of some of
these heavier elements tellurium and
indium is limited and we may not have
enough of these elements in the Earth's
crust to scale up to the terawatts level
and so we'll hear two points of view one
in favour of development of new
materials and one against and just to
situate ourselves in a position or a
location where these debates actually do
happen you can imagine yourself for
example in the Office of Science and
Technology Policy which reports directly
to Barack Obama these are about 50 PhDs
who are all in an office under the
direction of a director thinking about
thinking deeply about some of the
scientific challenges that our nation
faces and the proper scientific response
coordinating amongst many agencies
including the DoD goe
NSF and so forth and so you can picture
yourselves in a debate in a lively
discussion all friendly but but really
with the potential to influence national
policy do we direct resource funds to
develop these novel earth-abundant
alternatives that we might need in 10
years time
or do we focus and allocate resources
elsewhere so welcome to two participants
up to the front
so folks want some insight into where
the office of science and technology
policy actually decided to go a
gentleman who took a version of this
course in Berkeley in 2003 I think it
was his name is Cyrus whadya graduated
with his PhD from Berkeley and actually
went off to join Office of Science and
Technology Policy
he took his class project for the pv
course which was analyzing alternative
materials and had a published that paper
that you read by cyrus whadya on
resource abundance that was published in
2009 for that work earned himself a TR
35 award from tech review and then
joined the Obama administration's OSTP
and has been developing the materials
genome project within OSTP the first
solicitation for her proposals was
issued I believe a week and a half ago
so that's funneled through the NSF but
it's a larger effort to develop some of
these materials involving NSF do-e DoD
and so forth so it actually did come to
fruition through through OSTP budgeting
is always the the big question though
because that of course gets done through
through the committee's and in in
Congress and ultimately reconciled
between the House and the Senate and has
to make it through OMB and finally to
the individual director it's that's how
things actually get done but it takes a
vision of OSTP sometimes to drive these
larger projects forward so wish him the
best we're going to describe the
efficiency limitations of a typical
solar cell now and what I'll do is I'll
pass around some of these books just to
again situate ourselves did I grab
Jennie Nelson's on the way out I thought
I did hmm okay
well Peter ruffles and oh yes absolutely
so there's two books that are entitled
physics of solar cells you can see it's
a very popular topic and one is the
photovoltaic handbook all refer to some
aspect of efficiency limits
and as you look through your your sheets
you'll you'll see at the bottom
typically the different pages of each of
the books listed here so the very first
thing that we should consider before we
get into PV technology we just have some
solar device looking at the Sun and the
Sun is radiating at it at 6000 Kelvin
5800 Kelvin and it the solar contraption
on the surface of the earth is radiating
back at the Sun with blackbody radiation
at 300 Kelvin so much lower power from
Stefan Boltzmann's law we know exactly
the amount of power being emitted by
that device so the two are radiating at
each other and they're in equilibrium
and that results in the very first same
we'll call it blackbody efficiency or
maximum solar heat engine efficiency
which would be around 86% so that's our
first fundamental cutoff now that 86% is
averaged over all wavelengths there
tends to be a wavelength dependence to
this as well so the next step was to say
okay well we know that we can't do
better than the theoretical
thermodynamic limit of one object
looking at another we but what is the
actual limit of a solar cell and this
was a question that the first developers
of the solar cell asked themselves so
Prince was one of the three of the team
that 1954 published on the crystalline
silicon solar cell device and very
quickly followed up with another article
here in JP focused on the theoretical
efficiency limit and a curve was
proposed looking much like this with two
data points for germanium and silicon
theoretical limits that is an power
density so not a conversion efficiency
per se but a power density and of course
assuming a certain input power density
one can calculate an efficiency from
there and Along Came well at this time
HT t ake Weiser had just moved over from
Germany to Palo Alto to the apricot barn
in and working with Shockley
the esteemed Shockley at the time to
develop a detailed balance model for
describing how a solar cell performance
or what its ultimate theoretical
efficiency limit could be now what a
detailed balance model does is it's just
basically accounting accounting for all
of the photons coming in and out of the
device through the photons the electron
hole pairs are generated this is
assuming a very high quality material
that does not have any form of
recombination other than radiative
recombination so we talked about the
different methods of limiting lifetime
radiative recombination is is the is one
of the methods of limiting performance
that occurs in high quality materials if
you have a poor quality material you'll
have non radiative recombination say
shockley-read-hall recombination but in
the detailed balance model only
radiative recombination was assumed that
way you can count number of photons
coming in and number of photons going
out of your device furthermore they
assumed that the mobility of carriers
was Infinite inside of their material a
few laughs over here coming from the
folks who are working on organic
materials but it's true they assume that
the the mobility was infinite such that
the separation of the quasi Fermi
energies throughout the entire device
was equal right so if you had a limited
mobility if you had a certain higher
density of carriers in the front than
toward the back you would have a
difference in the chemical potential
through the thickness of your device
they assumed infinite mobility so it was
a very simple yet elegant ly insightful
model that upon first submission was
rejected so the first time they
submitted this model for publication it
was rejected outright and it took them
another several months of edits probably
bout a year and they resubmitted it and
then it became a sleeper paper
it wasn't sighted that much if you go to
the web of science for example and look
up this manuscript you'll see that the
number of citations in the early years
was rather limited nowadays there isn't
a talk about the fundamental efficiency
of a solar cell without mentioning the
shockley-queisser efficiency limit
that's coming directly from this paper
right here and that serves as a
motivational story for you if your paper
is rejected
remember that now you're along with some
several esteemed individuals who have
set precedent in the field of
photovoltaics and are no bail worthy so
that's my personal opinion
if you fall into that category don't
feel discouraged regroup and find a way
to make your paper better you have a
copy of this manuscript right here by
the way in your handouts for today
and interestingly through their detailed
balance model they obtained an ultimate
efficiency versus versus wavelength or
energy in this case a curve that looks
very similar to the curve that you
derived in your earlier homeworks where
you just assumed to loss mechanisms one
was non absorption of light and the
other was thermalization of carriers so
the the detailed balance model the the
way they reached this point is different
fundamentally different the physics that
was assumed is is basically listed out
right here but the end result is fairly
similar to the rough back of the
envelope calculation that you performed
in an earlier homework so again just to
go up they assume that the photons with
energies greater than the bandgap are
absorbed create one electron hole pair
they assume thermalization so these were
your two assumptions that you did in the
homework then they do a few additional
things they assume that radiative losses
occur within the material that not every
carrier is collected that's important so
they you have radiative losses in your
device so that reduces the performance
and then they assume further that there
is a thermodynamic loss in their device
in other words that you don't extract
the full bandgap of energy but that
there is a thermodynamic loss as you go
from band to band which would be the
bandgap energy to the difference or
separation of the quasi Fermi energies
which is this Delta mu here which is the
change in the chemical potential from
the front side to the back side of the
device so there are some additional loss
terms that were included for a full
description of the detailed balance
limit and all the math I definitely
encourage you to go
who this website is well Peter Versalles
text does a wonderful job describing
this and of course you can you have your
paper here you can read through the
original paper yourself or perhaps
suggested at an upcoming journal meeting
for your group here is the calculation
of the detailed balance limit for a M 0
and M one point five four essentially as
a function of bandgap coming from the PV
cd-rom and you can see how silicon and
gallium arsenide are pretty close to the
theoretical maximum in terms of in terms
of the theoretical maximum efficiency
for a single bandgap semiconductor
material so we're this curve right here
again is just representing one bandgap
material with a single band gap material
so let's take it from here and venture
forward into some more realistic
performance reduction effects we can for
instance take into account recombination
mechanisms that aren't only for example
that aren't only radiative we can take
ours a recombination we can take
shockley-read-hall recombination to
account we can also take what's called
photon recycling into account so what is
photon recycling photon recycling is
when you have a radiative recombination
event and that photon gets trapped
within the material it's not allowed to
escape but it gets trapped because for
example off the top there's a index of
refraction mismatch or the angle at
which it tries to exit is is is two
oblique and so you have total internal
reflection within your device and you
eventually have reabsorption so that's
called photon recycling because you have
a radiative recombination event it emits
a photon inside of your solar cell
device and that photon bounces around a
few more times until it's reabsorbed
generating another electron hole pair
and that is the essentially the major
boost and some of these ultra-thin
high-performance solar cell materials
such as the Alta devices record
efficiency 28% gallium arsenide cell as
the ability to do this photon recycling
okay now how do you modify the detailed
balance limit to account for finite
mobility I suspect this corner of the
room is is going to want to hear this
there is a beautiful piece of work done
by Malthus
his PhD thesis sorry that the PhD thesis
is even more insightful than the
manuscript in terms of actually breaking
down each individual component a great
deal of modeling went into this
including photon recycling including
some things that are very difficult to
model and the effect of finite mobility
was calculated on the on a modified
detailed balance limit model and you can
see the let's see number one that curve
that's starting here at the twenty that
is for a mobility that is close to the
optimal if you drop by an order of
magnitude or two orders of magnitude
relative to the to the say the the
maximum ability inside of a material
your performance begins to degrade
considerably and now you can understand
why silicon or crystal and silicon which
has say electron or hole mobilities
somewhere in the range of a few hundreds
of centimeters centimeters squared per
volt second so keep that number in your
minds and the order of hundreds of
centimeter square per volt second whole
mobility now you compare to a morphus
silicon which has something in the range
of 10 to the minus 3 to 10 to the minus
one centimeter square per volt second
and you can begin to see why those
materials with poor mobilities are
really impacted in terms of their
performance there is a method to
calculate the impact of limited mobility
on device performance and if that
intrigues you I would definitely refer
you to this manuscript I'm one very
simple way to think about it is at least
for a band conductor you would have a
certain diffusion length at least a
first-order would be the diffusivity
times the lifetime and the diffusivity
would be related to the mobility inside
of your material so your mobility is
factoring into your diffusion length and
the diffusion length is affecting how
many charge carriers are collected so
that's a simple way to to think about
the problem a similar related approach
that kind of pulls all of this together
in a graphical form is at the very last
page pages some of the very last pages
of Peterborough fools text and this is
going through the efficiency
calculations that we just saw starting
from a certain amount of light that's
not
the light that is absorbed so that's
efficiency lost mechanism number one and
for a thin device let's say light
trapping isn't perfect where at around
seventy four percent efficiency of light
trapping of absorption of light let's
say now that we have a thermalization
event that results in about a thirty
three percent loss or down to sixty
seven percent efficiency for the
thermalization of charge carries just
the step so now our combined efficiency
is going to be the multiplicative
product of those two so just the
thermalization of charge carriers
results in a thirty three percent drop
of an efficiency now there's a delta
between say the band to band and the
actual chemical potential inside of our
material once we consider the ensemble
of carriers not just those free carriers
but the ensemble of carriers which is
going to dictate the the ultimate
potential so we have some carriers that
are excited and others that aren't these
thermodynamic losses result in another
thirty six percent drop and finally fill
factor losses which represent the solar
cell and practical operation when we
have serious resistance and so forth
another eleven percent so if we multiply
these four numbers together we drop down
to twenty eight in the beauty of doing
breaking things out like this and what
peterhall does very nicely is dives into
each of these in great detail and
explains to you exactly how those
numbers are derived the beauty of doing
something like this is you can pick the
lowest number say 64 and 67 and say i
want to work on those i want to make my
PhD thesis about those parameters
because that has the biggest impact and
that's what you can do with an analysis
like this now you can take this further
you can say well these are only four of
the many parameters that impact
performance i would like to I would like
to look at many many more and that's
what one has done for crystalline
silicon which is arguably the most
researched in from the point of view of
physical understanding advanced solar
cell technology we can see a variety of
performance loss mechanisms that have
been taken to account inside of the
crystalline silicon devices this was a
an invited talk by dick Swanson the
founder of Sun power former professor at
Stanford who
who pulled this together a very nice
presentation he speaks with authority
because son power produces the highest
efficiency crystalline silicon solar
cell device commercially and
interestingly right here this is the
thermodynamic limit and the calculated
limit efficiency versus time so we start
from prints that was a very first one
and we have shockley-queisser up there
and so forth so the the theoretical
limit of solar cell performance has also
changed with time and their calculations
vary so it's important to be able to
understand this as well as you go into
it and here is the actual best
laboratory performance so if we had for
example the twenty five percent
efficient cell over there it would
already be higher than some of the
earlier efficiency calculations for a
crystalline silicon what Dix wants and
thinks is the practical limit is right
there that's the Swanson prediction that
we won't get much above twenty six
percent for a crystal silicon so loss
mechanisms visualized right here and
several good readings on efficiency
limits what I'm going to do is pause
here there is still some material in
your text and some really cool demos
that we're going to have to wait until
next week to see
you